are you enjoying your Nintendo switch
problem-free well some people have
experienced issues especially with their
left joy comes connection but Nintendo
says despite that issue its new console
is not facing any widespread technical
problem I'm Matt this is a game spot
news update and make sure to LIKE and
subscribe to keep up to date on
everything Nintendo in a statement to
Time magazine Nintendo said we take
great pride in creating quality products
and we want our consumers to have a
positive experience it is common with
any new innovative consumer technology
for consumers to have questions a
Nintendo switch is no exception there
are no widespread technical problems and
all issues are being handled promptly
including the reports regarding the left
joy convoluted connection Nintendo added
that if you are experiencing issues you
should go to its online support site and
contact its consumer service team the
left joy con issue isn't the only
problem the switches face so far there
have also been reports of the doc
scratching the switches screen and the
causal finish being worn down after the
application of stickers and skin oh
right and those cartridges tastes really
terrible which isn't really a problem
unless you like sticking those things in
your mouth anyway if you're about to
start playing with new Zelda on your
switch make sure to watch our video on
the nine things we wish we knew before
starting breath of the wild
[Music]